first man is directed by Damien Chazelle
and stars Ryan Gosling as Neil Armstrong
the first man to set foot on the moon
and it's the story of his family life
and the difficulties leading up to
getting on that mission and how much it
really took out of him as a person and
his family to get up there and wear some
space exploration films like say Apollo
13 focused more on the actual space
exploration portion of the characters
lives this focuses more on his family
the medical condition that afflicted his
young daughter Karen and how much pain
that caused him and his family
I've loved both of Shels previous films
whiplash in particular I think is a
masterpiece and will probably go down as
a masterpiece as years go by a lot of
land I really really love and so
naturally it Ryan Gosling you know it's
it's a great combination of things he's
kind of my man crush and so pretty
excited to see this movie and I left a
little conflicted although I do like the
movie and I do recommend that you see
the movie well start with a positive
first the acting is phenomenal Gosling
and Claire Foy are amazing in the film
the idea of approaching this story from
a very personal perspective when most
people would expect you to make a big
blockbuster film with a lot of special
effects that everyone gets really
excited about like say gravity for
instance is a different idea seeing the
family at dinner the father having to
explain to his kids he might not come
back from this journey the mom being
understandably concerned about that
that's an approach that you don't
normally see in space movies it's
usually focused on the mission
unfortunately for me the film feels
almost a bit detached as well and it's
strange to me that a film that takes so
much time in trying to show this man's
life and what he went through and his
family feels almost like you're not
really experiencing it because he's just
so stoic and it's not necessarily
because Gosling tends to act that way
when he when he takes roles he's a very
quiet actor which I've always liked
about him I mean yeah he never tries to
go big he's never like going for the
Oscar or whatever he's usually a very
quiet and subdued actor which I love
about him but for this character despite
showing us so much of his family life I
just didn't really feel like I knew that
much about him it's also pretty long
and whenever the space stuff happens
it's actually quite riveting the special
effects are incredible that they're
seamless Chazelle uses handheld cam for
pretty much the entire film and so
there's a lot of sequences that do feel
very rugged and gritty in the sense that
you feel like you're there there's some
times where the ship they're in is
rattling so much that you feel like it's
going to blast apart even though you
know history it's very frightening and
the space scenes are suspenseful more so
than some I've seen those were some of
my favorite aspects of the film the fact
that as you watch it and you see these
guys in this ship it kind of feels like
it's gonna fall apart so much of what we
see is practical in camera you can tell
and there isn't an over-reliance on CG
to tell the story and that's something I
loved about it the sequences on the moon
I mean it just looks like you're looking
at the moon it's really astounding what
they can do with movie today and I have
to praise first man on a technical level
because as a film that showcases NASA
the training tries to hit the beats of
history properly it's pretty
unprecedented and I was really impressed
with that and I don't want to ruin it
for you because I actually looked it up
and I couldn't find any accounts of this
I could have been wrong but I know they
interviewed the family and so if this is
like new information what he actually
does on the moon that's really touching
and I would love to know if that
actually happened if it didn't that's
disappointing that they're sort of
making it theatrical but nevertheless I
think this is his movie you should see I
think it has amazing performances and
technically it's very well presented but
I just felt very detached from Neil
Armstrong's character which is
unfortunate because the movie makes such
an attempt at making you feel connected
with him I'm gonna give first man a be
guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
you
[Music]